la recherche porte sur le développement
de l'écouter dans les amitiés entre
l'adolescence et l'urgence de l'âge
adulte on sait qu'à l'adolescence les
amis occupe une place vraiment important
pour les jeunes alors que chez les
jeunes d'adieu c'est l'amoureux qui
reprend ce rôle là moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de regarder c est ce
que les différentes et de parcours
amoureux que les jeunes 11 ans d'absence
et l'immersion sa large adultes a une
influence sur l'inclusion et leurs
meilleurs amis
ça dépend des jeunes qui ont très peu de
relâchement bronze ceux qui en ont en
moyens et ceux qui en ont beaucoup les
supermarchés de montrer que il ya
effectivement un lien qui est très fort
mais uniquement chez les garçons c'est à
dire que plus les garçons ont deux
partenaires amoureux que lui vont
affirmer qu'ils ont de l'intimité dans
leur amitié et saint-omer à nous
demander si la socialisation des jeunes
le fait qu'on élève et garçons
probablement lors qu'ils ont pu avoir
plus de rachat morose c'est quelque
chose que j'aime beaucoup de prestige
est-ce que sa différence et les teams
tison et de leurs amis
c'est une question à laquelle on pouvait
répondre dans de prochains titres